bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique l'émission
consacrée aux coulisses de la
mondialisation des multinationales dans
le radar de l'europe la commission
européenne propose un texte sur le
devoir de vigilance des entreprises en
gros bruxelles veut les contraindre à
respecter les droits de l'homme et à
protéger l'environnement et ce sur toute
la chaîne de leurs sous traitants pour
en parler je reçois charles-henri
bohringer avocat associé au cabinet
clifford chance bonjour charles henri
morange et bonjour à l'est la mrc c'est
quoi l'idée l'europe trouve que les
multinationales sont irresponsables je
crois pas je crois que ça fait longtemps
que les grandes institutions
internationales souhaitent inviter les
entreprises à prendre leur part de
responsabilité dans la gestion du risque
environnemental et les droits de l'homme
depuis 2011 nenê unis d'abord l' ocde et
l'europe vient prendre sa part
aujourd'hui en imposant un système
beaucoup plus opérationnelles que la
soft law qui avait été privilégié
jusqu'à maintenant l'idée c'est quoi
c'est d'éviter ce fameux drame par
exemple en 2013 durana plaza se
stimulent qui s'écroule sur des ouvriers
plus du 1000 morts c'est ça c'est
exactement ça l'idée le leur à naples at
avait créé une grande émotion dans
l'ordre international en france avait
donné lieu à la loi de vigilance de 2017
et l'europe emboîte le pas inspiré
d'ailleurs par la france en partie avec
cette loi pour que les entreprises
soient responsables de l'ensemble de
leur chaîne de valeur et non pas
seulement de leurs propres périmètre
donc c'est à dire qu'il ya eu un défaut
de responsabilité
je sais pas si c'est un défaut c'est à
dire il faut changer de paradigme c'est
à dire que les entreprises ne peuvent
pas se limiter à leur propre périmètre
immo qu'elle soit responsable sur
l'enchaînent l'ensemble de leur chaîne
d'approvisionnement d'une part et en
aval sur la vente la distribution le
transport de leurs produits et même le
recyclage de l'eau vous l'avez dit la
france précurseur sur cette question
2017 et les allemands 2021 ce qu'est ce
que ça a donné concrètement 2017 cinq
ans de recul alors c'est la loi de 2010
est arrivé dans un contexte où il y
avait but coup de lois en matière de
conformité donc les entreprises ont pris
ça avec un peu de distance au début mais
les ong la société civile a fait son
travail je dirais et a dénoncé un
certain nombre d'entreprises en
engageant des procédures judiciaires et
aujourd'hui la loi de vigilance
française très inspiré d'ailleurs un
texte très solide et bien trouve son
application et les entreprises mettent
en place sur toute leur chaîne
d'approvisionnement des mesures de
vérification et d'identification des
risques pour les gérer au mieux
concrètement donc cette proposition de
ceux pour l'instant ça pas été voté de
la commission européenne oblige à quoi
concrètement en fait cette proposition
vous avez raison de le dire après il y
aura une discussion avec le conseil et
le parlement oblige les entreprises à
les grandes entreprises européennes et
non européennes à identifier tous les
impacts négatifs sur les droits de
l'homme et sur l'environnement de leurs
activités dans leur périmètre et au sein
de la chaîne de valeur les identifier
les gérer les réduire au minimum ça veut
dire que pour l obligation de
cartographier ces risques là on est
d'accord donc de fournir un document qui
cartographient tout ça c'est ça déjà la
première absolument la première étape
étape c'est la cartographie c'est
l'identification des risques étaient
bien posé à plat sa chaîne de valeur et
voir de manière directe ou indirecte à
travers toute sa chaîne contractuels là
où il pourrait y avoir des risques
d'impacts négatifs sur l'environnement
ou sur les droits humains qui ça
concerne exactement dans un premier
temps et qui dans sa 2e dans un premier
temps ça va concerner les grandes
entreprises européennes c'est à dire
celles qui font plus que 150 millions de
chiffre d'affaires ouais qui ont plus de
500 salariés des grandes entreprises
européennes et aussi les grandes
entreprises non européennes qui auront
un chiffre d'affaires de plus de 150
millions d'euros sur le marché unique
mais d'abord ces entreprises la
stratégie de la commission je pense
qu'elle sera reprise dans le cadre du
trilogue c'est en quelque sorte une
stratégie d' influence on commence par
les acteurs les plus influents qui ont
la chaîne de valeur la plus profonde
pour pouvoir par une fois une sorte de
capillarité répandre les bonnes
pratiques pratique à travers toute la
chaîne de valeur les deuxièmes temps et
deuxième temps ce sera deux ans reprise
plus petit 40 millions de chiffre
d'affaires 250 salariés mais seulement
sur certains secteurs jugés comme étant
les plus à risque particulier le textile
qui est bien connu comme étant à risque
en matière de droits humains à
l'environnement
l'extraction minière énergies fossiles
et puis l'agriculture bien entendu
concrètement je suis n'entrera
étrangères 1 hors europe j'ai un siège
en europe fait plus de x millions en
effet je peux être poursuivi par une
instance européenne parce que j'ai pas
fais mon travail en afrique en asie et
c'est donc dimension extra territoriale
ou pas absolument et ça c'est très
important d'insister là dessus je crois
que toute la philosophie ou une partie
de la philosophie de ce texte et c'était
également le cas de la loi de vigilance
c'est d'éviter que les grandes
entreprises exportent leurs risques vers
des pays moins dix ans donc il faut que
toute la chaîne de valeur soient
concernés y compris sur des entreprises
partenaires qui se situent dans des pays
tiers on peut penser à l'asie l'afrique
et c'est donc effectivement il faudra
que ces risques soient identifiés et
gérer y compris à l'étranger comment je
fais moi si je suis une grande
multinationale et que j'ai plus de 10000
sous traitants concrètement je fais
comment pour les surveiller tous vous
fait l'écho d'une des grandes
préoccupations je dirais des grandes
entreprises vous savez qu'il ya une
activité intense de lobbying auprès de
la commission à la fois des grandes
entreprises mais aussi des ong chacune
dans un sens différent est l'une des
préoccupations c'était de dire nous
sommes d'accord je dirais pour pour
gérer ces risques là parce que parce que
c'est essentiel pour notre activité mais
il faut qu'on ait un périmètre qui soit
bien défini parce que nous nous
travaillons avec des dizaines voire des
centaines de milliers de deux
partenaires est donc la solution très
pragmatique qui a été trouvé par la
commission c'est de limiter cette chaîne
de valeur à ce qu'ils appellent les
relations commerciales établies qui
d'ailleurs alors c'est une notion de
droit français donc on peut on peut s'en
féliciter elle est très familière pour
les juristes droit français c'est ça
veut dire quoi la relation commerciale
établie ça veut dire les relations qui
s'inscrivent dans la durée déjà ou en
vocation à s'inscrire dans la durée
d'une part de relation contractuelle
d'autre part et enfin qui sont
significatives dans la chaîne de valeur
donc ça ne peut pas être une relation je
dirais accidentelle ou isolées dans la
chaîne de valeur il faut qu'elle soit
durable et signifie que si mon sous
traitants fait appel occasionnellement à
un autre sous traitant ça rend pas dans
le périmètre on s'envoie redire on
pourra pas reprocher à la grande
entreprise européenne concernées par le
texte de ne pas avoir identifié le
risque se situant au niveau de ce
partenaire très indirect est très isolée
par rapport à la chaîne de valeur en
question qui va superviser deux femmes
alors c'est un des grands apports je
crois du texte et que qui va plus loin
que la loi de vigilance française et je
crois que le texte allemand c'est que le
texte européen prévoit qu'il y aura des
autorités administratives indépendantes
le terme indépendant est un terrain
important qu'ils vont s'occuper de la
supervision du respect de ses
obligations de dieu dit jones parler par
les entreprises donc il y aura dans
chaque pays une autorité qui supervisera
et qui sera capable d'enquêter d'en
joindre des entreprises est aussi une
allusion de les sanctionner à une des
sanctions de nature administrative et
non pas pénal mais qui sont décrites
comme devant être suffisamment
dissuasives donc été fondée sur le
chiffre d'affaires de l'entreprise il y
avait en gros comme deux approches celle
de la commission mais aussi celle du
parlement européen qui était qualifié de
plus dur plus sévère envers les
multinationales
oui c'est vrai qu'il ya une résolution
en 2021 du parlement qui était on
pourrait dire plus ambitieuse à bien des
égards on pourrait aussi dire plus
idéologique qui est inquiète et pourquoi
les plus vielles de le idéologique parce
que peut-être qu'elle allait trop loin
pour permettre une application effective
et proportionnée en réalité de ces
objectifs est parfois lorsque vous allez
trop loin et que les entreprises dans
tout simplement pas les ressources vous
faites un texte pour rien je pense que
la proche de la commission a été de
réduire un petit peu la voilure
attention le débat n'est pas terminé le
parlement a son mot à dire de réduire un
peu la voilure mais pour faire un texte
qui trouvera une application très
concrète et qui aura un impact qui sera
règlement une directive directive a donc
moins trente mois contraignant quand
même moins directement contraignant la
directive demandera une transposition de
la part des états donc une adaptation
d'état à état mais avec des principes
quand même qu'ils sont très claires dans
la directive critiques des ong quand
même notamment sur la charge de la
preuve lorsqu'il ya des dégâts
occasionnés sur l'environnement où les
droits humains la charge de la preuve
beaucoup trop lourde pour la victime
disent les ong je comprends cette
critique mais c'est vrai que vous avez
évoqué la résolution du parlement
européen celle ci prévoyait un
inversement de la charge de là c'est à
dire c'est à dire que dans l'hypothèse
où une victime une personne se trouve
victime d'un dommage à l'environnement
aux droits de l'homme et bien dans le
texte de du parlement elle avait la
possibilité de demander à l'entreprise
de prouver elle même s'était à
l'entreprise de prouver qu'elle avait
respecté ses obligations et l'inde dans
le système qui est proposée par la
commission il appartient la victime qui
est le demandeur à l'action judiciaire
de démontrer que l'entreprise a failli à
ses obligations c'est une charge de la
preuve qui est difficile
incontestablement aux critiques des ong
là aussi les petites entreprises qui
exportent importe c'est pas suffisamment
concernés et notamment comme vous le
disiez le textile et c'est
encore une fois là je crois que 1 d un
des principes cardinaux qui a été retenu
par la commission c'est la
proportionnalité dans un souci
d'efficacité les petites entreprises les
micro-entreprises les s est mise comme
dit la commission ne sont pas en mesure
aujourd'hui
d'appliquer des normes aussi ambitieuses
que celles qui sont prévues par le texte
donc la stratégie c'est une stratégie d'
influence le texte parle parle de
leverage on utilise les plus grandes
entreprises et on leur demande d'imposer
elle aux entreprises partenaires plus
petit avec lesquels elle travaille les
meilleures pratiques dernière question
rapide le calendrier calendrier là vous
allez rentrer dans la phase de trilogue
et une fois que la directive aura pris
sa forme définitive les les états auront
deux ans pour la 12 23 2 23 de 25 à peu
près merci beaucoup chaleur y bohringer
pour vos réponses l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique est terminée
mais évidemment vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission sur france 24 points
comme à revoir
[Musique]